hello and welcome to this video
Rose 66 I should definitely adjust the
number there okay so I haven't had a
French for a while it was curious to see
how the defend against the exchange this
one okay it's a good line but should be
success little bit strange
it just gives less flexibility then
maybe I should have played rookie once
before
okay it's not a body eutteum
[Music]
to think about this for mood like a
queen t2 here
yeah okay Black has this test the
isolated porn but there are some things
going on that are not so easy to handle
the main thing is this pin this pin is
annoying g5 I can take on g5 so that
doesn't work interesting move
huh I don't know if I want to give it up
but it might not be such a big issue if
I do like just centralized 93 23 it's
quite nice
and maybe no g5 huh ever then he has to
reckon with rupees 6 g5 rookie 6 fe 6
queen g6 check getting interesting
anyway he went back and now I have
Knight to g4 winning the pawns I think
too early like Bishop f6 95 this b2
hanging so it doesn't really do the
trick I've got huge pressure on the on
the porn anyway if 3 is not a move I
love to play maybe I should just do this
him tempting him to take
yeah that I can do that
moving the bishop is not easy to do here
now it's very difficult to keep d5
should have six Bishop f6 okay 828 95 95
Bishop b2 97 Queen e2 just about hordes
just about
if I go 95 immediately 9555 should age
for no I can take then so let's do it
down to 24 seconds
that wasn't very necessary Bishop age 48
they got rooked de5 coming with a pretty
awkward pin
I always had a nice development edge it
sort of was some preserved the whole
time
Wow 56 okay this is hanging this is
singing okay
Wow
three seconds is not much
really not
the bishop moves I go rook d7 keeping
everything active Bishop the very likely
move g6 Queen f3 cannot cover this with
any good move
I've got some time back again not sure
that this was the best ah he he lost
some time okay yeah and I kind of knew
that I had to play quickly but sometimes
it catches you by surprise when the
clock is ticking down yeah Bishop d6 is
an odd movie and maybe I can really
become who you want if him I mean c4 is
most frequently see but this should be
seven is also quite often played it just
like if I take here then black often
does castles and tries to get this back
made him and after Bishop d6 is a small
possible and they have this chick but I
thought we should be six could be played
maybe there is not g5 in these
situations but it's often not that clear
because after castles you what does it
sound you can do this but
and here I think it's probably not
enough compensation sometimes black gets
compensation and such such line yeah
anyway the way we had it it was just
transposing to to a line that they know
and that is I think a little bit more
comfortable of white you're just not
easily playing this g5 is not possible
and night before what you did is very
slow talk to you one night takes and
assess this is just week and I've got
pressure yeah we should be 794 after
that I'm very happy
rook c8 something like that is probably
right now if 3 or 95 is not good
no it's also fine it looked like a
strong move um if he takes it I have
this of this caption so had to take
loopy aid and he I didn't find a win
really so I saw this this okay this one
okay I did not calculate that farm that
looks indeed very nice yeah I'm going to
win this pawn and have a dominant night
so Knight takes what I did wasn't as
convincing because of this called the
ship d6 defense last one yeah g-force is
kind of what I have to do it's clearly
better but it it continues I should have
taken b7 yo but okay I had no time I was
mostly playing for control and moves
like h3 just give more stability with no
time okay I can take a step
would have been stronger but I wanted
easy moves and so like here it takes
takes overtaking here I can play many
moves quickly and distribution and ta
lost some time yeah okay
thanks for watching